humans are storytellers we have always
been storytellers before we wrote stuff
down people wouldn't sit around in the
dark around a campfire and tell stories
some of the stories were about the hunt
some of the stories were about being
that time that that did something
happened when we were out trying to
gather food the time that that bet that
crater chased you that the time we're
storytellers
and then we make up fiction as well and
do you it's a funny thing I honestly
wasn't explicitly conscious about like I
got a like open this thing up to the
whole world kind of thing it just like
did the universe was just pushing this
way and I knew that the next step in my
journey was to now take this to other
people to gather like-minded folks yes
to help them experience the healing that
I experienced it it's a standard shamans
journey yeah the moon did you know the
the wounded healer boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sockin we are still in
Cambridge in Massachusetts we are now
going to be talking about how we are the
stories we tell we have Bob Cohen
joining us on the show hello hey Howie
thank you so much for coming on really
appreciate it thank you for having me
it's been a great pleasure yes it's such
a pleasure meeting you and learning
about your journey and what you're
building Bob Cohen is the founder of
Ouroboros story our the true tales of
healing and altered states which is an
unscripted storytelling project that
focuses on consciousness hacking
practices plant medicines traditional
psychedelics healing and maximizing our
potential as human beings and you can
check out the links in the bio below to
their Facebook page or a Bohr story hour
as well as you can get in touch with
their gmail or a Bohr story our at
gmail.com and we want to give a shout
out to the whole living center which is
where we're shooting this interview act
this is Amelia sabotage go space she's
the founder it's a psychotherapy health
coaching an online workshop space right
here in Mass Ave in Cambridge so huge
shout out to her and let's jump right
into a bob so
love asking our guests we find ourselves
as stewards of earth what is your
current take on the state of humanity
the current take on the state of
humanity I think we are in a crisis of
compassion people are people are so
focused on taking care of themselves and
their families and their tribe that
they've lost this idea of we being
eating this whole thing all together and
it's it informs people's opinions and
it's it's as simple as things like so
I'm not young so I argue politics and
Facebook with my my meter might
middle-aged my middle-aged friends and
my conservative and I don't live in an
echo chamber so I'd make sure to call to
be friends across political spectra but
we have conversations we miss each other
because they're thinking utilitarian
they're thinking theoretical and I'm
thinking how can we take care of people
that need to be taken care of and we
just we we just miss each other and I
feel like if they could remember that
there's more to life than that you know
that that $150 dollar bottle of fancy
wine that they want to buy and that the
person that we across on the street may
not have a place to live may not have
food that maybe we can buy a $50 bottle
of wine and do something better with
that other hundred a crisis of
compassion yeah yeah are such a deep
focus on our own sustenance and also the
sustance of our families in our nuclear
families that we have forgotten about
the interdependent global village but
even global yes but even just even in
your towns in your town even on the
street you're that neighbor that you
know that you don't get along with well
what's going on with that it's and it's
the kind of thing where I don't know how
you teach that I mean and then I don't
know how I don't know how to engage that
in a conversation where people who are
more
utilitarian don't feel judged because
I'm saying well I'm better than you
because you know I actually give a [ __ ]
about people and you know all you care
about is you know your BMW 5-series and
that you know that that that vacation
you want to go on it you know in Italy
the the message that you bub the
broadcasting right now I think is is is
critical for us to reflect on how we
actually have more meaning and
fulfillment in our lives when we do
compassionate things with the extra that
we have yeah with all that we have not
just the extra yeah yeah with all that
you know beat show up and be with people
yeah yeah yeah this is now you're
getting a really good taste of Bob I
love this I love this so much all right
Bob was actually born in New York City
and then he moved to Boston around the
age of 28 and I want you to teach people
about this journey that you've been on
and coming out of the psychedelic closet
well well unlike maybe some of your
guests I have a way longer journey so
I'll try I'll do what I can to keep this
brief so in the mid 80s I was in a ph.d
program at Stony Brook University for
English literature and we had some
family issues and we my I had just
gotten married in my wife and I decided
that it was in our best interest is our
own nuclear family to be someplace else
than where we were so we moved from
Stony Brook to Boston and the original
intention was to stay there for a year
so I was in the third Everson third year
of the program I'd finished up my my
coursework and was getting ready to do
orals and write a dissertation and a
year turned into 30 years it's funny how
the it's funny how these things happen
you know you put down roots even if you
don't intend even I didn't intend to put
down roots here I still feel like I
still feel like you know I'm still
suffering from for me what do we call
that about we'll move on so we get here
we get we open space for that last
thought that you were having just a
minute ago yeah I was struggling over
words we'll talk about works later on so
I lost the word that you know that
though okay I'll called cultural
dissonance you're like I feel I feel
like you culture New England's very
different from culture in New York and
so I have never felt like I fit in here
you think about that that all Frost poem
you know the mending wall' the the
payoff line the last line of the poem is
good fences make good neighbors and that
very much informs the different psyches
between New York and New England I mean
my standard joke is that if you're on
line in New York and you're there for
any length of time you can start a
conversation with the person next to you
and it could be you know something
stupid is you know having to back in the
day like how about George Steinbrenner's
Indian not right here when you talk to
someone on line anywhere to a an actual
New Englander I always feel like they
looking for the wet spot in my pants you
know like they're sure I'm crazy because
like why are you talking to me I don't
know you and so you know you can't like
there's like this cultural dissonance
and the funny thing is that in my family
I'm the least New Yorker of all of my
family I mean I looked like I've lost my
accent and I'm not is I'm not as out
there I'm I was actually demure one in
my family but here I've always been
viewed as the person who's way out there
and that way I used to be in a selectman
in my town and they're like that was my
reputation because I said I said what
was on my mind
mm-hm and I didn't pull punches number
was never unkind well maybe sometimes
but I tried not to be but it was this
idea of well keep your thoughts to
yourself you know just put a smile on
your face and remember good fences make
good neighbors and then take us all the
way up until yes her story you told in
two years ago when you were starting up
yeah Norah Boris did you want me to jump
like just because you know from from
there you know I I did a number of
things I was a full-time freelance
writer for for for about ten years I had
a small web design practice that I kind
of did him between and then my wife was
the CEO of a national nonprofit
organization so by the time we
my late 30s or mid-thirties we you know
that the subject the family came up and
we wanted we wanted to have the family
and she had a six-figure salary and in
in in benefits and I had a really cool
job I wrote about I did adventure
journalism so I go on like rock climbing
trips ice ice climbing trips scuba
diving like you have cut holes and lakes
and gods God scuba diving under under
under under the ice but of course that
doesn't pay real well so we agreed that
I would stay home and raise the kids and
that went all the way to about 2008 when
and my wife so my wife had been in her
job when she was you know well where's
your like 29 or so until I'm will say
how old she is anymore I won't say how
old she is now gotta get in trouble and
there was a she had a crisis at work she
did the the president of the the Board
of Directors decided he wanted to spend
money to enrich his friends and she
relied mm-hm and he wasn't having it so
he actually assaulted her in after a
board meeting she brought up the issue
about the assault the board circled the
wagons around the president the man
mm-hmm
and as a result of that she ended up
losing her job and so we went from
six-figure six-figure salary to holy
[ __ ] what are we gonna do now
so that was around - that was around
2008 and over the last well it's just
like getting out of eleven years now
we've been sort of like working to deal
with that trauma and the effects on our
family life our home life our finances I
mean I don't you may want to in store in
storing our like I'm pretty open about
it I mean almost lost my house a few
times we really had to scramble and
struggle to keep
our home and to keep our family together
and to make sure that our children
didn't understood what was going on but
didn't feel the deep effects of the
trauma from what was going on for both
of us and so my wife stories really not
mine to tell so I'll tell my story in
this you know it was it was hard and
almost losing your house multiple times
yeah yeah I know recalibrate with
children how to deal with finances yeah
how to deal with finances and don't
forget now I'd been out of the job
market for a bunch of years so yeah
either even though you know even though
I've got a master's degree with their
you know 30 credits toward a PhD it's
like what have you done for me lately is
really how you know really what it was
so it was not easy for me to kind of
plug in and find you know and find
something that worked so we we worked
hard at that and around 2013 we found
ourselves in a situation where we didn't
have health insurance and my family
every frame every family has a curse so
my family's curse is bad arteries so my
dad his brother their father and whoever
else were back in the old country
they all died in their 50s from from
from heart attacks and we had the the
money that we had within the assets I
kind of pushed us outside the bounds of
qualifying for MassHealth its but we
would periodically try so it by the type
by the summer of 2013 I was very sick
like we're just walking down I would
break out into a sweat walking down to
the to the mailbox and so I I kind of
resolved myself - well I have a good
life insurance policy I don't want to
leave my family I don't want to burden
my family with medical debt well I guess
I'm gonna die and I just I like off my
life and somehow or another this is like
this is really like where the journey
begins in earnest
we've periodically make these calls to
MassHealth so my wife called and she
got a woman on the phone who's name was
loose Luc which is light mm-hmm somehow
or another I don't never know how this
worked somehow or another we found
ourselves with unit being covered by
MassHealth Wow within a week I was at
Brigham and Women's Hospital having
heart surgery when they when they went
when they you know when they looked at
when they looked at the data about three
of my arteries arteries were 99% blocked
no my fourth one was 85% blocked and my
doctors looked at me and said how are
you not dead so here's a really really
cool thing
your heart actually creates the
peripheral blood vessels when the big
ones get when the big ones get blocked
so it was i keeping me going Wow now
maybe nine person 99 percent five three
three oh yeah and then here's this a
really crazy thing that happened so as
I'm you know as we're kind of like
moving into this like late summer this
lately into the late summer I fall
asleep and I have a dream so I'm among
the things I do is I'm a writer so I
wrote a novel a bunch of years ago that
I've been I just keep on rewriting and
rewriting and rewriting so I had I fall
asleep I had this dream I'm in a room
with who this person who's like my
literary mentor and we're talking about
the story and he says to me that's a
good story but I got an other word for
the end that you have to work on and sit
and the name of the main character it's
going to be Toula tol aah so okay well
what the hell stole her right okay so he
says to me over and over again tol a hto
lah - yo lah I wake up
Toula is on the tip of my tongue mm-hmm
I go to my handy-dandy phone hidding
know google Tola it's a word that
appears in the bible two times and one
of the places that it whatever the place
is it appears is I think it's Psalm 24
it's my God my God why have you why have
you forsaken me and so I read through
the
but I read through the you know but I
pulled up my Bible app ready to read
read the read the poem and I am a
card-carrying atheist I experienced
grace my body like I like something
happened to my body in that moment and
it was like Moya Wow and then and then
mid sorry I told the story a little out
of sequence that happens then loose
comes along then I'm in then I'm in the
hospital so I have three big-ass stents
there like just long they and they were
they were so blocked and they were so
brittle that the doctor said that if I
were say five or six years older they
would have cracked my chest and done a
bypass instead they puts they put in
stents and really cool they went through
an artery and my wrists like these
needed them through the groin yeah where
it's like a big pain in the ass
within two days I went from profoundly
sick to like I could raw if they would
have let me I could have gone out
running the two days later
wow what a crazy change in state yeah
and it was like body it was like this
big ship
and so you know we're a later on we're
gonna talk about about how psychedelics
interact with our consciousness but
there are a lot of ways that you know
that you can have these consciousness
altering events that kind of lead me to
the idea that really what psychedelics
do and what any of these practices do is
they open up doors for us and that they
bleed us to a sort to the dust source of
this source yes which is us yes right
it's it's it's this reframing thing so
here I am now I'm not dead because I
fully expected to be dead by September
or October of 2013
fully completely and then it was like
holy [ __ ] I'm not gonna die now why
because I don't you know in a funny sort
of way you know then the idea of like
dying from a heart attack like that gets
me off the suicide hook right my
sufferings over my family gets some
money
and I get paid I get relief from my pain
because at that you know at that time we
still haven't sorted are we still really
had the store it's order in our
situation only now I'm not dead so
there's this initial state of euphoria
we're like wow you know I feel great you
know and then there's like well now what
meaning yeah like now now what and that
actually made me more depressed than it
was so we hit the summer 2014 and I'm at
in my mind like I'm like I'm ready to
check out again and I came across an
article I'm pretty I might I did there
were three articles that I read that
summer one was in The Washington Post
one was in The New Yorker and one was I
forget where the other one was one of
them was a Michael Pollan article so I
we get a we could it would be like a
nice tidy story to say Michael Pollan
got me here so they were talking about
the research at Johns Hopkins and why
you the psilocybin research so I thought
to myself well yeah you know I tried
mushrooms a couple times in 1980 when I
hitchhiked around the country that
sounds like that could work it was a
very pleasant experience I just needed
to you know you know just to get messed
up and this idea was born that that
psychedelics were gonna sort of like
help me reconfigure my being only I want
to see my mid-50s and so the joke I'd
like to tell about is when you're say
like 16 to 24 25 26 if you're still in
school you know you know the drug
dealers you know where to go to score
your acid to score your mushrooms to
score whatever is you want so you get
into the year late 20s early 30s you
still have friends that are in school so
you know people who know people and then
eventually you don't know anybody sound
like alright so what am I going to do so
I do two things I started educating
myself about psychedelics so I'm hitting
you going hitting JSTOR and you're doing
reading reading the journal stuff
in the neuroscience reading them reading
reading reading the research trying to
like educate myself on the language and
like understanding what's going on and
it's just just push push push push
and eventually the understanding comes
and in the process of doing that self
education I discovered the horizons new
perspectives in psychedelics conference
so it was in New York now at that time
we really didn't have any money and I'm
like I got to go there I have to go to I
have to go to horizons so fortunately
it's in New York City it's in the
village and for I'm from New York so I
was able to get to New York stay at my
mom's house out on Long Island and take
take the train in for both days in the
conference so we're midway through the
conference and the I think it was the
NYU team that was up but I forget what
the hell they were talking about but it
was like some some research and so they
were doing work on you end-of-life
end-of-life trauma and something else so
they're like we get to the Q&A portion
of the presentation and I stand up and I
go this is really great I've something
really encouraged about this you know
you're taking care of Wally all these
people that are fundamentally safe like
if you're working you're working with
people are gonna be dead in six months
like you can experiment with them with
these things and so I go well what I
said was I said I'm not asking you where
where I can score drugs but you know can
you help a brother out so it's like I
got the laugh in the room that I won't
help brother out yeah yeah give me help
a brother out you know and you know when
are you going but that then went to like
so you know when it when this is going
to be for your garden-variety depressive
Xining so anxious people who just want
to blow their brains out because life is
so painful they suck so haram prefer um
you know we get that we don't we'll get
there eventually you know have patience
so like meanwhile like the so that's
that's that that's that's September
that's early October of 2014 I'm losing
my [ __ ] mind
and I literally put her up around my
neck they went into my garage
hooking up on the ladder and I used to
rock climb so I netted tie knots yeah
and I designed it so that the you saw
that the force would so that the force
of me putting the weight on it would
drop down and wasn't swaying like I got
this like I'll play it out and then I
thought to myself my kids are gonna come
home to find me this way yeah and so I
got to have and so at the you know at
the at the conference at the after I
after I had that's that's a profound
shift when you think about the people
that are gonna be affected by the
decision oh yeah yeah yeah it's it's
because it's not about you at that point
you know it really really isn't it's
like it's you're relate it's that
compassion thing right it's that really
it's what's your relationship to the
people in your life and what you know
what do you you know what how much can
you take so that because me being
miserable is way better than me killing
myself and there's also a way to not be
miserable and that's what the discovery
right did right this is yes this is the
discovery so at the at the Horizons
conference this woman came up to me at
the very end of the day and it sees for
the first she's she's the second angel I
actually felt like an image everything
like there are a number of like really
concrete angels who came into my life so
there's the angel for my dream there's
loose and then there's a woman named
Mary Kay from New York City and she saw
me like through the cheekiness three
through the you know through me through
this thing of the snarky thing and she
said I heard you I know how you feel I
know somebody but I wanted to meet you
first to make sure to have a
conversation with you
I'm gonna go talk to this guy and I'll
tell love cut me off
I'll find you tomorrow and I'll let you
know what's what so the other Sunday and
the conference she comes up to me she
gives me a name she there's a sky in the
Upper West Side who trips it's and he
worked he worked with MDMA and with
mushrooms so my interest did that that
was mushrooms in part because I was
afraid MDMA is a basal constrictor and
so with you know with having the stance
I was had some concerns because it's a
methamphetamine based drug so I had some
concerns about how that might affect
money my new apparatus I so we would go
so I call him up and he says ok you can
come but I have we have a network of
people there's somebody in Providence
once you know I'll get you in touch with
that person so I'm like really desperate
at this point so he connects me with
this put this person in Providence we
talk and I think at the end of the day
I'm going to use I'm going to use the
the pronouns that disguise gender then
so I think they were concerned that they
wouldn't be able to handle my situation
while I was tripping Wow
they like to use a very high dose of
mushrooms 7 grams which is a which is
the law and so they said I really can't
we couldn't like we couldn't meet each
other and they said well I'm gonna
connect you with therapists that would
start you out of lower well did with
this person with this person who
actually was not a psychotherapist
interesting me enough I'm gonna kill you
I'm gonna bounce you back to our friend
in New York okay I call up our friend in
New York arrangements are made
January of 2015 I'm in New York City
which is right down the street from
where I was born there's a porn website
so I was born in Columbia Presbyterian
Hospital which is like 210 Street it's
off Morningside Heights
so I'm you know maybe like 15 blocks
from there lying on Riverside in a couch
and Riverside Drive
so we started out with two and a half
grams and mushrooms and I got stuck in a
loop so but my New York friend says well
you seem to be stuck in a loop do you
want more okay sure so I ended up taking
five grams on my first trip whoa what
loop were you stuck in Oh I'm also
practicing Zen Buddhist so I got stuck
in this loop where I realized the absurd
the Zen practice and the colon practice
that your III practice a form of Korean
Zen
so they call with Kong Hans but it's koa
and people know it as and I was kind of
I was stuck on one and it been stuck on
went for a really long time so then I
started having this conversation with
the dead founder of this dead dead
korean monk founder of the of the
quantum school is N and I like and I was
just and I'm just doing like I'm doing I
like gesticulate ng and and you know and
I like this but this is this is [ __ ]
ridiculous like why do I have to know
you know you know if Bodhi unibody
Dharma came to chart you know the China
and me whatever who gives a [ __ ] if he's
got a beard or not right so they up the
dose the impasse yes and so it's all I'm
like looping looping looping looping so
that so my friend from New York you know
ups and does too and he did some funky
stuff with sound so once I got past that
it was the most extraordinary thing I
say I think they're like revisiting my
infancy like I regrets back to I were
rest back to you to like yeah - baby
state and I I want to be careful about
how I always say this because some
things are not my stories to tell but I
need it to be loved in a way that I
wasn't yes
and we all do yeah yeah and so I
actually went back and gave myself yes
that stuff that was missing from me yes
and it was this profoundly healing thing
and then like so three three three big
three big things happened in and and
that and that experience so there's this
piece then the other piece is that my
dad he was a lieutenant in a New York
City Police Department
he retired on the captain's on the
captain's list it's a really brilliant
guy but he also didn't know how to play
with it didn't matter
he was like all about power and you know
he just like didn't how to play the
politics end of the thing so he never
like like he could have been even smart
enough to be police commissioner he got
stuck in like the civil service thing
and then he ended up like ending his
life in a way that was not sad
factory for because he died a year after
he retired from the police department
and then my great uncle Henry made he
was a painter and sculptor in New York
City so his parents were Polish
immigrants and he's completely
self-taught his work is extraordinary
it's exquisite
same thing though like he couldn't like
he couldn't they couldn't figure out how
to like get out of their own way to to
open up themselves to the world so that
they could the world can embrace them
and they're and they're brilliant so
these were really smart guys and so I
went back to them so I went back like
and I had a conversation with him I said
look you guys are all done said I got
this now I will carry this forward for
us so you don't have to worry anymore
you you got you guys can rest that's
great and then the other kind of crazy
thing was like I was like doing all
these crazy rituals and whatever like
I'm out I'm saying like most I was a
bed-wetter and I didn't really stop
traumatic it was and so I went through
this whole thing with rituals and I
ended up like pouring water all over my
all down my shirt like that on my pants
and then changing yeah so I come up out
of this you know I come up out of this
this experience having healed like done
like don't you know done ancestor work
done you know like done fundamental
trauma work and I'm like wow this is you
know this is like this is the deal yes
but I'm still back with this problem of
where do I score drugs and while finding
mean it further meaning yeah in life
yeah yep yeah interesting you know what
a what an insane series of life
experiences from the clogged arteries
near the heart 99% clogged to the
needing to find meaning when you
regained that state change and then all
the way to all the trauma that was
healed and the and what you experienced
with your first psilocybin experience
psychedelic the assisted psychotherapy
and all the way up to you know to where
you're at now and and
I'm really excited to be able to talk
about that because I think it's so
fascinating that you've taken what was
some of the most profound experiences of
your life and you've really built on top
of them and shown it made spaces for
other people to be able to express
themselves at their fullest as well yeah
yeah yeah
so I can't square drugs more research I
grow my own mushrooms and it's I kind of
like I work that out so I don't have
since 16 but well through 2015
University misty and I don't have
anybody to trip's it for me so now I'm
full around I'm experimenting with micro
dosing micro dosing and you know I said
a program you know five value two
followed the following protocol
meticulously yeah do you know yes got it
you had a digital scale you know way
down you know way down - oh yeah all
that all that fun said how often were
you dosing I did a total of from 2015
till last until last year to the
beginning of 2018 I did a total of six
rounds of six six rounds of micro dosing
so it's four it's 40 days and then I
would not dose what you know I wouldn't
take any for a while because I wanted us
does the idea was I didn't want to be
dependent on on drugs totally so you
would do like maybe a gram or something
you don't know point one gram 0.1 so
little micro dosing that's really low so
point one every day for 40 you know I
have the other day every third day every
every day
so the bottom protocol is yes a tenth of
a tenth of an active dose okay and you
take Neary dose every fourth day every
fourth day so then I tell you have your
time of sobriety and then another dose
right so then you did it ten times over
40 days well you write ten times it so
that it wasn't you you do that and then
then you take a couple big arrests right
and yeah and then do it and what were
you experiencing on the days that you
would take the point one grams
hard opening more so than on the control
days
well did the idea with the idea with
micro dosing is to suck perceptual so
it's not unlike taking Prozac so it's
we're only with that without all those
shitty side-effects like not being able
to get hard-on so you know you you you
don't feel anything explicit but it's
this kind of gradual thing that really
really you think of it like when we when
when someone has has has been in extreme
exposure we don't throw we don't throw
them in hot water we gradually raise up
their temperature so it's that same it
was that same thing like just gradually
yeah over the course of a couple of
years open my heart yeah yeah a little
bit by little bit by interesting and
then as you're experiencing that where
are you finding differences in you know
and your heart opening up is this
amongst the finding meaning in life is
this with finding meaning and family and
your children and your community where
was it most with purpose Cedric it
starts with for me it started with my
relationship with myself like you know
they people say all the time that you
can't love other people until you love
yourself
yeah and so it was that because you we
have this conversation when people
talking about forgiving like forgiving
is not about letting the guy off the
hook that did you dirty it's about
letting yourself off the hook for having
been done dirty yeah because you know
there's there's always that thought well
if I had done this that person wouldn't
hurt me but had done that you know said
that victim-blaming thing yeah and so it
was like it kind of like established
that part of my journey forward in what
I cook I call these my bonus years yeah
obviously here's I'm supposed to be dead
so so I got to you know I got to
reinvent you know I got to reinvent
myself yes yes and then be able to
inspire other people yeah yeah yeah so
we kind of go along with this and then
every year after I kept on going back to
to two horizons so after my third year I
got connected up with
a guy named Lex Belger who used to be
part of symposium and we just like we
hit it off we had fun chatting with each
other
and in my 13 my third her eyes that says
2014-15 so 2016 he invited me back to
the after to the after-party at his
place to events died
that's bedford-stuyvesant for you folks
who learned from New York which he used
to be one of the worst neighborhoods in
Brooklyn I mean like Sierra
my dad worked in bed-stuy in the
seventies you know we're back when there
were 2,500 murders a year in New York so
it was like it was it used to be
dangerous place so I find myself at this
at this party and I'm the oldest person
there by bite a lot but it's whenever I
come I'm tickled that you know someone
would think to invite me to something
like that it's like part of this like
whole rebirth thing so I'm there so I'm
talking with wonderful exes roommates
actually Mary Kate's daughter Catherine
know this is now another angel in the in
the story so I tell them the story about
the about standing up and saying you
can't help her brother round she goes
that was Shiho that was that's funny I
go yeah we all thought you were a narc
so we're you know we've got a good
chuckle that yeah we got a good chuckle
out of it you know there's like if
there's a funny I don't we don't have
time to do it so it's actually a funny
drug story at that party but anyway you
know we talked Solex floats back into
the conversation and he says you know we
kind of like relate to sting he goes oh
that was you know like yeah he goes you
got a company selects one of the things
Lex did was he actually did story he did
he organized story telling things he
goes you gotta come to my thing in
Brooklyn and I'd whoa okay
so he invited me it was at a place
called hell kitchen which i think is in
it's either a vet's tire or Bushwick I
forget which but he goes you got a comic
saw okay well as long as I can crash on
your couch no problem so a month later
I'm now in a you know a hit in you know
the in the hip capital of the universe
you in the hit the hipster capital of
the universe telling a story about my
friend my tourney too
you know that my journey to psychedelics
excellent and it was like yeah so I'm a
ride I was on 60 yeah 2016 so I'm a
writer and I tell stories and this kind
of like falls right in and what's really
cool is that it got me out of the
preparation for telling unscripted
storytelling for me it's very different
from when I'm writing a story yeah
because there were no notes yes and I
composed the entire story without ever
writing it down a paper and I would
drive around in my car and practice and
so you know I had me like you know have
my key type it all you know hit all
three marks in the you know they had the
Irish to telling the story all right
yeah
I got it I got this down we in and it
came off really well so I'm out
falou with my micro dosing and we had
never had a really great time I know I
really dig telling stories so Alexa
comes back to like scum comes up to
Boston that so now we're getting to the
I guess the spring of 2017 the
Northeastern's SSDP so that students for
sensible drug policy yes group was doing
sort of like the shout outs of them yeah
and also shout out to smile yeah it
smell it yeah and shout out to rick
doblin and leona sananda and maps yep we
love maps maps dork please go check them
out yeah psychedelics is the
psychotherapy they're so far along with
helping make the movement happen yeah
students for sensible drug policy is a
very important organization and they're
really getting into the minds of young
people yeah yeah so yeah so so real cool
so let LexisNexis doing this is you know
hosting the storytelling thing so he
asked me to come and share my story
again so that was actually funny night
because I started out my story with does
anybody know where I can score LSD
ayahuasca mushrooms and they you know
I'm pretty good at this like the whole
like the whole room was like did he just
ask for to buy trucks yeah and then you
know I go into you know this dish spiel
that I did the story that I just told
and then at the end of the night a very
personal I become friends with a very a
very dear young man came up
later on Denise's here I gotta he
invited me into the bathroom he tore out
a sheet he tore off like you tore off
like three or four hits of acid wrapped
in a piece of aprons idiot
yeah awesome so it's like so we do this
now now I did but also at that also at
that event were some people from what
it's called the Boston Athiya genic
network so it's really it's a Facebook
group and we say what's the term before
and everyone seems to use it was a group
of like-minded people I think that's
what people said now you know like leave
the Mafia so he's a friend of us he's a
good fellow right you know in the
psychedelic community we're like-minded
people or like hearted people if you
like yeah better yeah
and they invited me to come to their
meetings so I'm like okay cool now I
have a place I have an audience where I
can develop this storytelling project
because I'm really dig into telling
stories so I go there I meet with a
woman named Leah Friedman she's one of
the founders have been and Nathaniel
Potter was another one of the founders
have been and a few other people and we
were meeting in this Booz Allen space
I'm the 24th floor and built on milk
Street like it's like ultra
you know 21st century corporate space
and wide open pool tables foosball all
the [ __ ] and this is where we're having
meetings about psychedelics yeah so I
get this idea like I want to tap this
audience and me and make the
storytelling thing you have so this
pushes us into the summer of 2017 yeah
awesome
we I started out just up the road here
is the kid the mock the Cambridge
democracy Center so they're like they're
a direct action
their mission is direct action so I call
them up to about space
my project wasn't quite right for them
they directed me to add organization
called makeshift Boston which is a
cooperative working space so freelancers
get together they do you know that they
work during the day they were at the
space out at night mm-hmm
so I make the arrangements to get the
space and they really dig this project
so they give me a good deal and that was
August of 2017 and that's when you went
up and gave your first talk at you yeah
that's right at my first storey tower
yeah and and you were refined at that
point because you had given the talk
couple times yes yeah yeah so I mean I
could just leave you know I had I had
like neither did I could do this and I
was also a public official so I'm pretty
I'm pretty comfortable talking in front
of crowds anyway I come and you had your
first your first stint in curation which
is great so you had to actually identify
several others to follow up right I you
after you intro'd it and then they also
told about their experiences yeah with
hacking consciousness yeah very
interesting
okay so then the okay so now the
formation of this happens we have your
big well we have your big story about
coming out and about you know dwell we
didn't even really get to like how you
ended up talking to your family in your
community and how hard that is to to do
that in the process yeah tell us a bit
about sure so again it all starts with
your relationship with yourself yes it's
I don't want to put the way it started
with my relationship with myself yes yes
am i okay with this because I mean this
is a fact of life until things change
guilty or illegal drugs and now I'm a
policeman son and Here I am taking
illegal drugs because I'd never really
I'm not a law breaker and I have to know
I had to get okay with that but things
were so like you know there was there
was a movement going on there was there
was the universe was pushing me in it
was gently not so gently guiding me in a
direction I almost
it's a correct course correction here
you know this is this is where we have
to go so I this is like part of how I
have been able to come out of the closet
was to learn to accept the guidance from
the universe and to get in touch with my
intuition yes yes and then that assisted
with getting touch with your family
right community right because if you do
in when we do things where we're a
little where there's shame involved it's
hard to engage other people so you're
confident in yourself and the way that
you are engaging with these with your
own consciousness hacking experiences
and then you engage with your family or
community based on your own confidence
with those experience exactly
so with family because I couldn't buy
drugs I had to grow mushrooms everybody
had to know I mean again I'm not gonna
hide things from my faith from my family
so everybody knew dad was growing drugs
he's a girl growin mushrooms yeah and
you know I was always very cautious to
either do to frame it and it's actually
how I framed in my mind anyway but it's
medicine
you know I'm growing that is because the
medicine the doctors give me don't ya
yes correct correct they make the
medicines the doctors give me make me
sicker yes correct perfect so this is so
this is what I'm doing that my for
thousands of years is what we've been
helping ourselves with natural
secretions of planet Earth of Gaia and
yeah and here we are
millenias later putting it as a ban a
civilizational ban so we can keep the
hierarchies in the economies and the
power
I mean if anybody's paying attention to
this this is medicine to make us feel
better it's not to get [ __ ] up
leave us alone let us let us get better
please prefer I mean for such a myriad
of reasons to and we'll get there well
actually let's get there cuz that was
the big point about the confidence with
the self to be able to engage with
coming out and please come out of the
psychedelic closet as soon as possible
have that confidence in yourself and
then talk to your family
coworkers on social media about to find
your communities that will support your
little your golden nuggets of
experiences with consciousness hacking
and but come out as soon as possible
because we need you in the world so bad
okay now I want to talk about I want you
to explain the importance of why you
started this because you know that
there's you had this profound change in
your own life from it and then you
thought that you could then open the
door to or a bore a story our for other
people to be able to come and feel that
similar profound change in their own
experiences share it with other people
build a community that's that these are
the big things yeah yeah
human beings are storytellers we've
always been storytellers before we wrote
stuff down people would sit around in
the dark around the campfire and tell
stories some of the stories were about
the hunt some of the stories were about
being that tire that that something
happened when we were out trying to
gather food the time that that bent that
crater chased you the time we're
storytellers and then we make up fiction
as well and dude it's a funny thing I
honestly wasn't explicitly conscious
about like I got a like open this thing
up to the whole world kind of thing it's
just like the universe was just pushing
this way and I knew that the next step
in my journey was to now take this to
other people to gather like-minded folks
yes to help them experience the healing
that I experienced it's a standard
shamans journey yeah the moon did you
know the the wounded healer yeah yeah
and so here I am okay and and believe me
when I tell you I was far from better
put it when I may still be far from
better but it takes so long it takes a
long time it's our whole journey yes our
whole journey so we do this and now in
the in the course of getting involved
with the with been I am now have access
to a community of people who
can I've solved I've solved the you know
the drug dealer conundrum
I now know people and then got
introduced to people who did that this
is a very important point I didn't
actually get to highlight it so much and
when you initially mentioned it but it
is so important to increase
accessibility to safety
yes safe yeah and well conducted
psychotherapy sessions this is so so
critical yeah yeah in in in in certain
ceremonies doing it from a ceremonial
point of view as well within ten yeah
yes
so we gets really to all through all the
twenty sixteen you know I'm just kind of
like working out the Kingston the
project and I started out where I was
highly curating the night it's like
picking speakers around subjects that
was my but that was my first model and
that worked to an extent and you know
some really some really cool things
happened as a result of that but the
universities me pushed me away from that
so it's just let things you know just
let things happen organically yes so we
go through like we would go through a
lot of twenty twenty twenty sixteen all
the 2016-2017 so we're in January of
2018 and I have a nice supply supply of
mushrooms out of my basement and I found
myself in possession of a day where
nobody was around and I go yeah I'm and
I think I'm gonna go go have a trip so I
get out I take measure out two and a
half grams I get my my covers I put on
the Johns Hopkins you didn't soundtrack
to mushroom trip being laying on the
laid out of my couch and I'm kind of
like falling into this you know like
nice and falling it's this nice trip and
I'm actually experiencing this for the
first time Wow but then I hear this
noise like
so there's all these their chainsaws
because I lived I lived in I live in the
country and I'm trying to like not pay
attention to that and you know stay you
know stay in my head and like hold on to
the Bliss and it just that noise just
wouldn't go away
so I'm you know I'm peaking on the
mushrooms I get up off my couch and look
out my window and I see this army of
guys cutting down one whenever one of my
neighbors trees so that the street I
live on it's really long everyone has
like two or three hundred feet of
frontage that what we're like not close
to one another yeah but I can see this
going on and there the way that they
were cutting down and was a big tree
then when they were cutting down by
you're lobbing the branches first and
then they were gonna cut wrong yeah yeah
and something really crazy happened
there was this transference of
consciousness with the tree Wow and I
suddenly found myself experiencing
directly the trees terminal agony yes
Wow
correct yeah yeah because it is also
connected yeah yeah
and that also I really this is the this
is a simulation exclusive I've never
told I have never told people this stuff
I've never told people this party that
I've told the story before but I've
never told this part of the story it was
very traumatic for me to leave graduate
school I mean it's a big hole for me
right now like I feel like I you know
I'm smart enough to be dr. Cullen I was
on track to be doctor Cohen I'm not dr.
Cohen so that kind of like limits were I
can teach and things like that so it's
like it's always been the sort of a
camping mood and there's just there's
crazy convergence of experiencing the
trees terminal agony but then also
re-experiencing the trauma of leaving
graduate school and like this idea of
like losing it like rip one love one
limit of time and thrown into a chipper
so we get to the end so like now the
trees the trees spirit is all but all
but God and I as an act of compassion
for the tree spirit I say I will take
you to ground
we together went I took I carried his
spirit back to the source yeah
interesting and so this is this kind of
interesting connection like going back
to the shamans journey thing so in
agrarian in agrarian cultures when
shamans had that that death rebirth
experience it's done where the spirit
goes to ground hunter-gatherers they had
their their bodies are flayed and then
reconstituted so I come from farmers
interestingly enough so we we go we go
to grab together so another part of the
shamanic experiences this idea that
parts of our soul break off and they go
someplace so that part of my soul rested
in the ground with the tree interesting
until March of 2017 and when an
opportunity to participate in an
ayahuasca ceremony came along and I go
to this thing and IA Iowa scab eat the
crap out of me so but in my second in my
second like the first one was like the
first one just it was just all about
just being able to survive the night
because it was being very intensive in
my second journey I actually had a
rebirth experience where I came like my
spirit came back up out of the ground
it was in the spring and it was it was
actually Mother's Day of the 2017 it was
that it was that weekend and that just
supercharged the story project it just
it was like BAM i'm reaiiy i'm reborn
like praise the lord you know move you
know i'm reborn yeah yeah the the amount
of experiences that you've now curated
for other people both as speakers as
well as attendees is incredible so
you've done you've done 21 of these
shares that's about one a month yeah
that you're doing and this is anywhere
from 20 to 40 people are showing up to
these you have people speaking on
altered states of consciousness
meditation psychedelics healing
helping with their addiction help
talking about ego death talking about
oneness and the feeling that the
speaker's the audience get when they're
sharing these experiences they're
they're able to communicate the golden
nuggets the audience is able to receive
there's a sense of community there's a
sense of awakening for audience members
to understand how other people have
grown and flourished through it and we
make that meaning between us when we
talk about these stories yeah we do it's
it's big because this is this is you
know crackpot theory 47 for me but the
way the way I think of communication is
that we have stuff in our heads that's
filtered through our experiences the
people to whom with whom we communicate
have their own set of experiences we
have some agreement on what words mean
more or less and then when you speak
them that meaning gets I think it gets
out here and together we sort of like
make something so in a place like in a
place like story era where we are in the
room together and mixing our energies
together there's stuff that there's
communication that goes on that's
nonverbal that's not the you not that
like that's beyond the idea of you know
nonverbal cues like gestures and facial
expressions energetically and so we we
were talking about this before about
about meaning-making it's the thing I
kind of like left out of it I left out
not a purposes just its I left that part
of it out aside this idea of being in
the space together and our energy
connecting like we communicate in this
deeper way and so we have this I tried
really hard when I talk about when I
talk about story our I own the dish or
tea would be easy to call them shows but
they're not they're shares
and it's this idea some everybody opens
their hearts
there are givers and receivers in these
things but the giving and the receiving
actually really does go both ways and
that's where we make the meaning that's
where we make the experience when that
happens and I I can't think of a city
well I'm trying to think now yeah I
can't think of a single time when
people didn't come up storytellers
didn't come up to me afterward and say
oh my god this was just so healing and
then you listen to the side
conversations after after after the
storytelling is done and everybody's
engaged in talking about what they heard
and the understanding that we're all
real miserable you know not in a way we
all are and it's like this idea that
we're not alone and we're not alone in
our suffering yes and it gets back to
what we talked about before with it you
know it was compassion the compassion
crisis we don't need each other in that
space anymore we don't meet each other
in the space of you know even if it's
not the same thing I'm miserable you're
miserable
we're human right booed the Buddha says
life the suffering that we all have that
in common you did not see and and and in
the Quaker we were all afraid of the
same [ __ ] we're all we all suffer and
it's just how we manifest our fear that
that that that you know that that shapes
what goes on and that gets back to you
know the you know the tagline of my
story ours we are the stories that we
tell ourselves Nazis tell a particular
story about the world
Quakers tell a different story about the
world people who take psychedelics tell
a third story about the world and you
know we could argue with the with with
the we can kind of like throw the
science into an psychedelics are you
know creative pathetic States kept me
biochemically we reorganize our brains
yeah we still do not understand the
relationship between the chemicals and
the reordering of our brains we like
head it's like the placebo effect
placebo effect works well why does it
work because what's the source of all
the healing you and me and it's just how
do we look at what door do we go in
through to get to the source to
understand that and that's like that's
like what if fundamentally what happens
at or borås story ours right is we're
opening that we're opening we're opening
up
and we're all going through the same
door we all have we are sharing a moment
we're sharing we're directly sharing and
experience yes yes this ability to open
the the communication to source to all
that is have space for that have space
for healing you have space for
storytelling you have space for
psychedelics have space for altered
states of consciousness for that love
and compassion is just we need more of
that we need more of these stories
around the world for people to feel more
comfortable talking about them and
you're doing exactly what's needed
you're actually you're actually going
even a step further and then you're
taking it on the road you're doing a
documentary here and the ones that you
just shares that you do here and then
you're also you're planning a one in
Providence one in Portland Maine with
potentially San Francisco and so this is
again this is one of those things where
can we spread the word across the world
can we get more people to do though or
more story hours I love that yeah
it's can we get a bunch of people in the
room together to acknowledge that we're
human one of the things I love about the
psychedelic community is and I don't put
this we're out and about in the world
your your your office you know you're
you know you bump into someone how you
doing yeah I'm doing it right when I'm
in spaces with people who are to do
psychedelics and we're sort of like I
can do how you do it like you get the
laundry list of the trauma like people
don't [ __ ] each other like they say
we here so how our ears how arm feeling
miserable how are you feeling miserable
because I care about you too and it's
like just opening just opening it up to
like not pretending that everything's
okay and not and not always that
occasionally it does come up that I am
feeling blissful or I am having tons of
love and compassion
yeah because sometimes it happens yeah
sometimes we're out the wild up yeah
well yeah and that we can give ourselves
more
times in that type of thing yeah I mean
for me I I don't I think everyone
everyone's journey is different with
everyone's life journey Stanford but
everyone's medicine journeys are
different as well and so for me like
it's all been this is like Bataan Death
March to you know to to be you know to
fix my my my ancestor trauma to fix my
trauma make the make a good world for my
kids you know put food on the table all
that crap but you actually do have bliss
from time to time so last year I went to
Firefly which is a regional burden in
Vermont and I wasn't I wasn't intending
to going it's another angel in my story
so but my friend Paige kind of just she
could jolt me into getting on the
waiting list so like okay I'll go on the
waiting list I didn't think I was gonna
get a ticket I got a ticket so now we're
now we're camping you know it's like
really hot we're camping and you know
we're a bunch of us all camping together
so everybody else what goes on it burns
a lot of turns and I kind of like wasn't
doing many I didn't really want to do a
whole lot of drugs I was like just
digging like being around free of people
who just felt free and the night of the
bug burn someone got the brilliant idea
of dropping acid and then at the peak of
at the peak of taking acid doing MDMA so
I believe that smoke and I believe
that's called candy flipping candy
flipping candy flipping Wow yeah and now
hopefully there's again responsible oh
absolutely
we are disclaimer responsible yes well
the thing is like we'd been camping
together all week and we know we
developed we were like a family and we
all stayed together and so the
responsible use will become added in a
second so I brought I actually did story
hour at that Firefly as well and we were
supposed to do I was supposed to do one
like didn't like the night of the bug
burned and I was like yeah we're not
gonna do that we are the story so we get
to you know we get to this lab being
open filled with it with the with with
the bug and we're all kind of like
sitting together in a knot and
we're tripping our hearts are wide open
it gets dark and for people who have
never been in the mountains
where there's no light pollution the sky
is just so different from when we're
looking at that look and looking up at
the sky at night in Cambridge and it was
this brilliant black fault with dieting
like the white diamonds just tweak like
and we were kind of like all we were was
really called not together it was we
actually had it was a consensual
platonic cuddle puddle mm-hmm and we're
all just kind of like pulled in together
and I felt the warmest and safest I've
probably ever felt in my entire life
from that night yeah and I had this they
had this vision where I might my mind
kind of like travel back through the
eons of time and imagined what humans
the way humans coexisted the way humans
existed before we had cities and towns
and we were Apes that cuddled together
for warmth yes on the you know in an
open field on the mountains because it
was dark and we were afraid and together
we were warm and we were loving and we
were we and it was just I felt just so
held and it taught that taught me like
in fact like what we are what human
beings really are yes that's what we are
all this other stuff you know just crap
out there the cars like all this yeah
the cars and building and surface-level
connections and money and economies and
all that other type of stuff is a very
very different feeling than the feeling
of laying there in a cuddle puddle where
you're looking up at the stars in an on
light polluted area when you're really
tapping into that feeling of oneness I
completely agree I'm glad you brought
that story up I want to I want to we
have a couple other things to hit on the
way out I want you to you you I mean you
gave us a little taste in this and we'll
have to talk about it more next time but
the way that we make meaning between us
with words I think such a fascinating
because we'll unpack more soon you
called it a words are leaky bucket
carrying meaning across the lines I
thought that was so funny it is yeah it
is very funny it's very funny and then I
want us to hit on the you know we've
been talking about this throughout the
conversation I think it's so important
to hit on your thoughts on science and
spirituality because these two things
are so they're so intertwined and
they're so beautifully able to guide us
in a direction of prosperity and certain
budget abundance yes yes
well the science and spirituality are
intertwined in our culture right I mean
it's not explicitly they're not don't
necessarily have to be split explicitly
connected but for somebody like me who
was born in your midst mid century mid
20th century with the mature history of
science and rational thought I went in
the in the direction of science I became
an atheist I stopped going to church and
it was it was all about materialism like
them like the way what can I see smell
taste touch luck in a measure and as I
its began this this this you know this
journey with psychedelics I really had
to sort of I had to be able to explain
for myself how these things worked with
the science before I can open up to the
spiritual part of it and even even like
even today I have to I have to have both
explanations I have to be able to say
well I know that you know that if I take
the tryptamine base it's like you die
like that
it's going to it's going to interfere
with my default mode neural network then
it's gonna cut it's going to cut off
communication to prefrontal cortex which
is the part of our brain that the
science value in rational thought
connects to the other parts opens things
up opens up your heart you know fires
stage 5-ht to a neuro receptor and it's
done reliably and it's dose related you
know I get needed to know all those
things to be to feel comfortable enough
to put it into my body to say okay I
understand how the
works except that when I got when I've
gotten into those altered states all
that [ __ ] goes out the window and when I
even I talked about this in the car when
we were driving over when I first
started the my might my practice really
kicked up with the ayahuasca so I did
last year I did eight or nine ayahuasca
ceremonies over 12 months plus the San
Pedro ceremony with authentic South
American folks like not like some dude
who know who new added make ayahuasca
tea who didn't have to [ __ ] together and
couldn't hold the space spiritually so
in my first three in my first three
journeys I have the storytelling project
going on so it's research for myself or
my project you know it's not to be it's
not the spiritual thing and so I very
meticulously took note of of what
happened as it happened with the idea
that I would plunk these things in on
the on the the hero's journey model
around about my third round about my
third ayahuasca ceremony I literally
lost the ability to process language I
wasn't lying I was I was lying on the
floor and I could hear people talking
sounded like Charlie Brown like wah wah
wah wah wah wah wah
I'm completely in my body like it's all
about how my body feels it's all about
it like I'm having thoughts but they're
not words it's it's you I don't want to
murder Noam Chomsky and over over over
simplified but but I remember you're in
grad school talking about this like idea
of like sub Lang in a sub language level
thinking yes and after I when I had that
experience going forward like the
remaining by in five or six ceremonies
after that I decided to go into the
space and to put down my observer mind
and completely embrace the journey and
not worry about what it meant and not
worry about being having to report back
to somebody about what what
yes and then being open to the changes
as they occur cause like something like
we haven't any money has ever done the
stuff like you know that there's I mean
it's it's like I'm it's me it's [ __ ]
wild like you just the experiences are
just like wow right it's the world's
best roller coaster ride and all you
have to do is lay on the floor and drink
drink drink drink a shot as a
responsibly invite all this type of
stuff yeah you're so right though with
sub language level thinking and
experience that feeling can just be so
critical towards the feelings of oneness
that we need to we need to desperately
good to and they're so intertwined we'll
get to talk more science the
spirituality as well next time we shot
let's do the two questions on the way
out of the show the first question is
are we in a simulation funny you should
say that
if my very first mushroom trip the the
the you know the the the the psychedelic
gods have been very kind to me because
they I have like a lot of inner work to
do but I got an opportunity for a very
brief moment to pop out of our reality
and I got a glimpse of the multiverse
and I saw infinite universes and you
know the the you know somehow or another
like I needed to know that
and then last month I what I did a San
Pedro ceremony with some folks who from
South America we had actually I'm going
to go practice with them in Ecuador in
in in July and I was lying I was like I
was like it was lying on the on the
ground feeling the mushrooms so the word
word hops up and like in my field
division and I'm looking at this because
I was trying to think if I was lying
there there was trying to think of
something this word word comes in so
they start laughing and about how it
certain words are mm-hmm and then I made
the universe stop
and then I learned to play with it and
so the idea that I can do that means
that this is not exactly real I mean
it's real to us it's we are the story we
tell like this the simulation kind of
comes back to this idea of we tell a
story about what our what our reality is
and like something when it when I'm when
I'm feeling less than benevolent I call
it a shared delusion and it's what it is
so yeah I think we live in a simulation
yeah the shared simulation yeah we all
live in interesting and then how about
the last question is what is the most
beautiful thing in the world I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna fall into a Harry
Potter metaphor here and in in in the in
the flow and the Philosopher's Stone or
Sorcerer's Stone depending on what part
of the world you come from there's a
part of the story where Harry fights
this thing called the mirror of error
said and when people look into the
mirror error said they see what they
wish that they were and Dumbledore tells
Harry Potter well what does content man
see in the mirror error said and it's
they see themselves exactly as they are
yes and that to me like the ability to
really be comfortable in our skin to
look at ourselves without the shame and
without the self-loathing and just to
say you know I see myself yeah but to me
I think because even we all get that we
wouldn't have all the we wouldn't be
doing all this on all this all these
awful things to each other because we
would be enough for ourselves
I believe that's the first time on the
show we've had that that as the answer
of looking at ourselves and and being in
the most content with the way that we
are confident and where we are at in our
life trajectory and in our own shoes
yeah that's just comfortable in Italy
like being comfortable with ourselves in
our own skin honestly that I mean it
that is my that's that is my spiritual
work yeah correct and and facilitating
that for for hundreds of other model and
yeah and then and then sharing this
across the world as well and then being
able to get the messages out and get
people going in their communities with
stuff like this yes Bob this has been so
awesome I love you so much thank you for
sharing thank you so much for having
journey with us it's been such an honor
yeah thank thank you thank you thank you
Bob Cohen everyone huge thank you for
tuning in we'd greatly appreciate it we
would love to hear thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking also shared
more conversations with doing
storytelling about hacking consciousness
with our families our friends our
co-workers online let's get the stories
rolling let's get more people talking
about this around the world make sure to
check out the links below to both the
facebook.com 4 slash or Boris story hour
as well as Ouroboros story hour at
gmail.com if you want to get in touch
again
Amelia thank you so much for letting us
use your space hole living center here
in Cambridge and also everyone check out
the links to simulation below help us
continue growing and impacting more
people and support the artists
entrepreneurs and organizations around
the world that you believe in and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon
Bob that was so awesome
I'm glad you liked it I can't believe
that you were almost dead and then you
came back and then you almost killed
yourself and then you profoundly changed
then you got this other side that you
needed and that you yeah and that you
did the Fadiman dosing this is such a
crazy [ __ ] cool dope awesome journey
I loved it so much and now you're doing
the hundreds of people yeah it's such a
cool journey I'm so glad that Julia made
this happen and it's funny I wasn't
going to do the hard thing and then I
said what the hell